als nächstes haben wir hier gucci oder
louis vitton also erstmal muss ich sagen
beides viel zu teuer etwas gedacht und
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hab natürlich euch jetzt
geholt heute mit einem sehr spannenden
video ich muss vorweg sagen idee kommen
nicht von mir
ich habe das auf youtube irgendwie
gesehen und fand das eigentlich ganz
cool die inspiration verlinkt sich in
der video beschreibung also dass nur so
vorne weg und zwar sollte es heute darum
gehen einfach ich sage mal so sich
selber so ein bisschen besser kennen zu
lernen und zwar geht es wohl was heißt
ja gut das ist schwer zu erklären also
es gibt ja auf der welt keine ahnung
neun milliarden menschen oder so und
jeder mensch hat ja so seine
eigenschaften und das bezogen auf ganz
viele verschiedene marken die halt ganz
viele verschiedene produkte herstellen
nach dem motto so welcher typ bin ich
bin ich eher so oder bin ich ja so ich
will gar nicht an gelabert ich denke ihr
werdet das verstehen und ihr könnt
natürlich auch fleißig in den
kommentaren kommentieren was ihr dann so
seien aber noch ganz kurz bevor wir
anfangen ich habe das wirklich noch nie
gesagt aber es ist ganz wichtig
irgendwie sind die youtube notifications
grad ein bisschen komisch deswegen macht
neben den abonnieren -button hier unter
dem video auf jeden fall die glocke an
damit ihr nichts mehr verpasst ist sehr
sehr wichtig und dann bekommt ihr auch
hier das video angezeigt ich würde mich
darüber freuen
also metzger für doch ein paar klasse
gern doch nach oben da und wir fangen an
mit der erste entscheidung und das ist
folgendes so wir haben ja als erstes
rewe oder edeka ja kennt eigentlich
jeder sehr große supermarktkette in
deutschland kann ich sofort sagen auf
jeden fall nicht edeka einfach aus dem
grund weil wir sofort um die ecke
wir haben einmal wenn man 100 meter in
die richtung gehen rewe und wenn man 500
meter in die richtung geht noch ein rewe
also hier ist alles voll mit re wird
deswegen bin ich halt sehr oft bei rewe
wobei ich auch sagen muss dass ich rede
echt toll finde edeka ist im vergleich
zu rewe denke ich ein bisschen günstiger
also reviers jetzt nicht mein lieblings
supermarkt so wir machen weiter mit der
nächste sache schreibt gerne den
kommentare wie sieht es bei euch rewe
oder edeka als nächstes haben wir hier
gucci oder louis vitton also erstmal
muss ich sagen beides viel zu teuer ich
würde niemals auf die idee kommen mit
shirt für 300 euro
zu kaufen einfach weil es auch nicht
geil ist aber wenn ich mich jetzt
entscheiden müsste dann würde ich louis
vitton nehmen eigentlich eindeutig
natürlich ist das jetzt nicht so
unbedingt die mega männer marke also ich
sehe da eigentlich war nur frauen drin
aber ich finde die sachen an sich
schöner
ja die sind zwar viel zu teuer ihr müsst
euch was in der produktion kostet so
eine dreiecks tasche vielleicht 20 euro
und die verkaufen die für 1700 aber wie
gesagt wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
dann die güter wie es bei euch schreibt
in die kommentare
und morgen kommt ein sehr cooles video
und zwar etwas neues überlegt morgen
kommt zwar noch nicht das ganze neue
davon aber es geht schon in die richtung
morgen 19 uhr nicht verpassen wir machen
weiter a
hier kann ich auch sofort sagen ganz
klar nicht bayern
ich war schon mit fünf jahren eigentlich
dortmund fan dann sind alle aus meiner
klasse bayern fan gewesen dann war ich
auch bei entfernt obwohl ich bayern
eigentlich gar nicht so machte also ich
schaue sehr gerne fußball und findet
deswegen auch borussia dortmund mit
abstand sympathischer und wenn bayern
gegen dortmund spielt hoffe ich immer
dass bayern verliert weil es zwar
letztes mal klappt er sagt nur für
bayern auf internationaler ebene bin ich
immer für bayern wenn heute kein
deutscher klub mehr drin ist aber so
generell auf jeden fall wo es ja
dortmund sowie kommt zum nächsten okay
wir haben hier news player oder nutella
und hier kann ich aber mit einem so
unfassbar ich erstmal wahrscheinlich
ziemlich viele displays weil ich gesagt
habe ich mal bayern nicht eine
entschuldigung auf jeden fall kann ich
hier mit 100.000 kilometer abstand auch
wenn das eigentlich gar keinen sinn
macht aber mit einem sehr sehr großen
abstand sagen dass nutella der geilste
brotaufstrich ist den man sich nur
vorstellen kann und wenn man seitdem man
klein ist jeden tag nutella ist dann
kann man auch nicht einfach mal
plötzlich zum frühstück nuss plays
einfach weiß ganz anders schmeckt für
mich schmeckt nichts wie nutella
ich kann nur teller sofort blind
erschmecken da wäre ich mir ganz sicher
und dieses display und alle anderen
marken die es noch gibt können so was
von einpacken
ihr könnt gerne in die kommentare
schreiben wie es bei euch so als
nächstes haben wir hier pepsi cola
das ding ist eigentlich ist das komisch
bei mir wenn ich in spanien im urlaub
bin trinke ich eigentlich fast nur pepsi
weil da gibt es irgendwie viel mehr pepp
sie als cola überall in jedem supermarkt
wird er sofort pepsi angezeigt angezeigt
ich finde das sind auf jeden fall beides
getränke die echt lecker sind
und ich könnte eigentlich jetzt nicht
sagen cola schmeckt mir besser als pepsi
aber in deutschland trinkt sich auf
jeden fall mehr coca cola einfach weil
es leichter zu bekommen ist würde ich
mal sagen und in spanien zum beispiel
pepsi ich finde da gibt es verschiedene
lebenssituationen firma jetzt mehr coca
cola oder pepsi trinken sollte im kino
zb auf jeden fall pepsi und sonst bei
sie nicht willkommen zu den nächsten
marken und zwar haben wir hier jetzt
ferrari porsche und lamborghini gleich
drei auf einmal drei luxusmarken was
autos angeht an sich kann ich erst mal
sagen alle drei marken sind natürlich
gerne so da kann ja niemand sagen
ferrari ist kein cooles auto jeder wert
zufriedenheit dann ferrari oder ein
porsche oder halten lambo wenn ich mich
jetzt für 1 davon entscheiden dürfte
ich würde mal sagen ferrari wäre eher
was für etwas ältere leute also da gibt
es für mich auf jeden fall attraktivere
automarken porsche finde ich auch
irgendwie gar nicht mehr besonders so
man sieht so viele porsche vor allem
hier in köln jeder familienvater fährt
ihr gefühlt mit einem porsche cayenne
durch die gegend den einzigen porsche
nicht echt richtig schön finde ist ein
panamera
ansonsten bin ich mit meinem mustang
viel mehr zufrieden irgendwie also
deswegen ganz klar lamborghini hier
würde ich liebend gerne haben aber ist
natürlich extrem teuer so wir machen
weiter und haben als nächstes bmw oder
audi also hier kann ich ein jahr zuvor
zwar genau die bmw ist zwar auch eine
akzeptable automarke nur ich kenne kein
bmw außerdem die acht den ich schön
finde oder den nicht herausstechen schön
findet auch dies würden wir das schon
mehr einfallen deswegen an dieser stelle
auf jeden fall audi schreibt ihr an eure
meinung in die kommentare
ja so leute mal sehen was wir noch haben
aber das habe ich schon gesucht und zwar
haben wir hier mcdonald's burger king
oder casey warum jetzt nicht andere fast
von morgen noch da drin sind keine
ahnung auf jeden fall bin ich gar nicht
mal so unbedingt der typ der öfter gerne
mal fast food ist mcdonald sowieso nicht
habe ich echt zu viel gegessen
anscheinend working erst recht nicht da
war ich auch in den letzten jahren
häufig deswegen moment auf jeden fall
kfc schreibt gerne in die kommentare wie
ist es bei euch die hot wings sind der
absolute oberhammer also die habe ich
jetzt zweimal wir gestern im letzten
monat soll wir machen weiter und haben
die
doch amazon oder ebay ich habe ja auf
beiden sachen schon bestellt in letzter
zeit wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen
habt schaust du dir auf jeden fall an
ich glaube es gibt kaum jemanden der
bevorzugt wenn ich irgendwas schnell
braucht bestelle ich nehmen wir amazon
nicht über ebay
keine ahnung warum aber ist halt so
deswegen würde ich einfach mal sagen
amazon und amazon räumt ja gerade auch
alles mögliche was irgendwie konkurrenz
darstellen könnte komplett aus dem weg
also hier würde ich sagen amazon sowas
haben wir noch das war's ja leute das
waren 8 sachen ich bin gespannt was ihr
so sagt schreibt es auf jeden fall in
die kommentare und vergesst nicht die
glocken zu machen gibt noch nach oben
für noch ein paar und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder um 19 uhr gibt es ein
neues cooles video ich hoffe ihr habt
noch einen angenehmen tag ich wünsche
euch morgen auch angenehm tag und hat
rein